c'est venu parce qu'effectivement j'ai
eu des témoignages dans ma
circonscription mais aussi sur les
plateaux télé de petits propriétaires
qui étaient victimes de squatteurs qui
galérait du coup eux-mêmes parce qu'il
se retrouvaient en difficulté financière
et qui traînait ça pendant des années et
des années on a eu aussi le cas de
locataires qui ne sont pas vraiment des
squatteurs mais qui ne payent plus leur
loyer pendant des années des années
Pierre et Marie ce que vous avez par
exemple reçu ici avec qui on a largement
discuté c'est exactement leur situation
pendant deux ans ils ont eu une
locataire qui s'est arrêtée de payer et
eux-mêmes ont été obligés de vivre en
fait dans une caravane à Marseille parce
que ils avaient une locataire qui payait
plus pendant deux ans donc ce qu'on
voulait faire avec cette loi ce que je
voulais faire avec mes collègues avec
une large majorité c'était durcir les
peines sur le squat en sorte qu'on les
triple mettre en place une procédure
d'expulsion Express qui fait qu'en 72
heures quand il y a quelqu'un dans votre
domicile il est sorti bravo et troisième
élément c'était dans le cas des
procédures de contentieux quand il y a
un impayé locatif accélérer les choses
pour que vous vous retrouviez plus dans
des situations vous avez deux trois
quatre années d'un pays pour les
accidents de parcours ça arrive on peut
avoir un mois de d'impayés de managera
pas et vous pouvez avoir un accident de
vie mais ça sert à rien ça arrive non
mais par contre il y a des gens qui sont
vraiment de bonne foi et qui et qui
malheureusement ont eu voilà un fait
dans leur vie qui ont fait kiffer qui
fait que ils sont en difficulté pendant
un laps de temps après moi ce que je
vise c'est ceux qui connaissent par cœur
les lois et qui se servent de la loi et
qui se servait de la loi pour faire des
abus qui mettaient des personnes dans
des situations inextricables comme on
l'a pu le voir ici et des personnes qui
n'étaient pas je vous disent c'était pas
des des personnes très fortunées c'est
des personnes qui ont travaillé toute
leur vie qui ont réussi à avoir un petit
appartement et qui perdait toutes leurs
économies à cause de personnes qui se
servaient de la loi pour commettre des
choses inacceptables et c'est surtout
sur ça que la loi est bien faite puisque
on peut voir cette loi ce que vous dites
c'est-à-dire que voilà on va tolérer
encore des personnes de trois mois qui
sont en difficulté et mais après je ça
aussi c'est les propriétaires qui font
cas par cas ils voient très bien si la
personne est de bonne faute de mauvaise
foi ça on le voit tout de suite et puis
les squatteur alors ça qu'un mec puisse
arriver chez toi casser ta porte se
faire parce que les mecs
ils sont envoyés du courrier donc on
voit donc après ils sont marcher sur la
tête on était dans le monde de gilbertez
le monde de ses amis les insoumis
excusez-moi la buvette au lieu d'être à
l'Assemblée nationale oui alors
dites-nous non mais il y a des choses
très bien dans la loi voulez-vous
féliciter notamment sur les loyers
impayés ça c'est extraordinaire le reste
monsieur très respectueusement c'est de
la poudre aux yeux ouais c'est ça ne
fonctionne pas et pourquoi non mais moi
ça fonctionne pourquoi ça fonctionnait
avant qu'on s'était pourri maintenant
vous tape mais mais toi mais sur les si
on t'écoute toi de rien ne fonctionner
au lieu d'un an de prison 45000 euros
d'amende mais quel squatteur va pouvoir
payer 45000
€. c'est pas ça la plus importante
exactement
plus tu es encore à côté non j'allais
j'allais j'allais à côté tu fais pipi à
côté
allez venir moi l'esprit de la loi qui
me choque comme toutes les associations
qui s'occupent de logement c'est que
plutôt que de résoudre le problème du
logement et des pauvres vous faites la
chasse aux pauvres encore une fois c'est
un gouvernement qui stigmatise les
pauvres parce que sans abris qu'est-ce
que vous faites pour eux
c'est inadmissible que tu es en train de
dire franchement Pierre et Marie c'était
des nantiste et les mecs mais arrête
de la loi tu dis tu nous dis dans cette
émission il ne sort que des bêtises de
ta maman
contre la loi de Monsieur vas-y une
table c'est c'est un logement à tout le
monde de taper sur des gens qui n'en
n'ont pas mais ça tu fais quoi tu fais
quoi tu fais quoi les pauvres gens qui
sont obligés de dormir dans une caravane
parce que leur maison exploitée le
monsieur le député qu'est-ce que vous
répondez
je réponds que ça n'est pas parce qu'on
est propriétaire qu'on est forcément
riche il y a des petits propriétaires
qui ont investi leur travail la sueur de
leur fronde dans un appartement soit
pour eux-mêmes soit pour du locatif et
la souffrance sociale des hommes peut
pas se faire au détriment des autres et
Pierre et Marie ce que vous avez reçu
que il y en a des centaines comme ça
c'est des petits propriétaires qui
vraiment ont souffert de la situation
dans laquelle ils étaient et on peut pas
leur dire bah écoutez tant pis pour vous
c'est comme ça vous avez fait le choix
d'avoir une allocataire une locataire
elle paie plus bah tant pis pour vous ça
vous déchumer parce que vous êtes
propriétaire et que par définition vous
seriez mieux loti que la locataire c'est
faux comme raisonnement j'ajouterai un
dernier principe
si on veut encourager dans la crise du
logement que vous évoquez et qui est
réel des propriétaires à investir dans
l'immobilier et à louer des logements
bravo probablement les rassurer le fait
que quand ils choisissent de louer
évident ils auront moins de problèmes
avec des locataires et que ça ira plus
difficile que vous envoyez c'est de dire
ça peut durer deux trois quatre ans à
bien faire mais il y aura de moins en
moins de pour louer et il y aura de plus
en plus de locataires de bonne foi en
galère parce qu'ils trouveront pas de
logement de propriétaires arriveront
parce que avec talent et encore une fois
respectueusement vous ne répondez pas à
la question vous parlez de propriétaire
qui pourront louer moi c'est pas ça le
problème le problème on comprend pas ce
que tu dis l'État ne fait rien pour
30000 personnes
je peux te parler 2 minutes là parce que
ça on est oui on est tous d'accord tu as
entendu ce qui a dit monsieur le député
mais il fait rien tu es encore tu es
encore comme dans toute ta vie tu es
encore comme dans toute ta vie à côté de
la plaque tu es hors sujet c'est quoi à
l'école que dès que tu connais une copie
à mon avis la prof te le rendez avec HS
hors sujet et hors sujets
18 sur moi à l'école je sais pas ce que
tu es devenu depuis regarde est-ce que
tu peux lire ce qui a marqué là
est-ce qu'on parle de la loi sur le
logement est-ce que c'est ça
on fera une autre émission un autre
débat là-dessus pour l'instant on est
sur les squatteurs mais Gilles tu
comprends le français les 18 cas 154
200k et c'est formidable il y en a
300000 mais c'est beaucoup plus long
j'espère qu'ils vont faire mieux je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi là-dessus
il est d'accord tu crois qu'on est tu
crois qu'on est ils sont contents de
voir des gens dehors excuse-moi
qu'est-ce qu'ils font pour eux mais il
faut qu'il fasse quelque chose je suis
d'accord mais bon mais oui mais
excuse-moi on parle de la loi sur les
squatteur pourquoi tu dis des conneries
anecdotique
mais il y en a plein des cas comme ça et
bien sûr il y en a plein on est d'accord
avec toi sur la loi sur logement on fera
une démission sur la loi sur logement
ils le font pas bon allez vas-y allez
dernier excuse-moi je t'aime beaucoup
mais là tu me tu me fais tu me mets
2 millions et demi de ménage qui
voudraient un logement social on fait
quoi pour on est d'accord avec toi
courage le squat ça encourage les gilles
on est d'accord avec toi on parle de ça
pourquoi tu pourquoi une fois de plus tu
es à côté de la plaque pourquoi toujours
à côté va voir tes copains à la buvette
voilà c'est pas mes copains
va appeler tes amis et bah la buvette
avec eux et va être bourré avec eux
merci bah si une Raymond il mélange il
mélange
entre les logements et les squats ils
veulent pas payer de loyer les
insupportable des logements ils veulent
payer bien sûr ils veulent travailler à
cause des squatteurs à cause des
squatteurs les propriétaires veulent
plus louer même si c'est des logements
sociaux même s'ils doivent payer que 200
€ parce qu'ils ont des aides ils vont
ils veulent payer ils veulent être en
règle même s'ils ont pas de loyer du
tout ce qui n'existe pas ils veulent
être les squatteurs ils ne veulent pas
être ils rentrent change les serrures il
reste chez toi et ils veulent pas payer
et il dégrade et après après ce bar il y
a juste un truc dans la loi et je pense
que ça peut être échangé C'est la trêve
hivernale vous avez pas changé ça pour
les squats il n'y a pas très vivable
donc la procédure de 72 heures elle
marche quelle que soit la saison quelle
que soit le mois de l'année et donc en
72 heures avec l'appli du préfet sans
procédure judiciaire vous aurez accès à
un peu violent mais sinon dans
l'ensemble moi je suis d'accord pour
rentrer ce soir chez vous et vous avez
quelqu'un dans votre canapé
parce qu'il y a des gens chez moi je
vais sortir un restaurant
maintenant ce sera rapide Géraldine
qu'est-ce que tu peux dire surtout parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de loi qui sont
formidables
on va s'en assurer on va bien mais on
aura forcément des louper faut se dire
les choses honnêtement on aura forcément
des louper avec des cas qui sont passés
à travers sur lesquels soit on a eu la
justice éditionnée soit une préfecture
qui a dysfonctionné je peux pas
m'engager en vous disant qu'à 100%
partout il y aura jamais une faille il y
a toujours des failles en toute
honnêteté on le sait tous mais en tout
cas avec cette loi on a essayé de
renforcer au maximum du maximum de ce
qu'on pouvait et on a essayé de boucher
les trous qui pouvaient y avoir dans la
raquette on comblera un maximum de
situation pour vous en receviez comment
vous avez le moins possible sur les
plateaux donc de bonne foi je vous
assure qu'on fera le maximum pour
qu'elle soit appliquées avec sévérités
parce qu'il y a pas de tolérance à avoir
sur les squatteurs il y a une tolérance
à voir avec des locataires fragiles mais
sur le squat il y a pas de tolérance à
avoir et
c'est bon
toute la gauche ou à gauche quelle
motivation en fait la motivation c'est
de d'excuser le squat en expliquant que
l'équateur attends avant
victimes de la difficulté sociale et
donc squatte parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix je trouve l'argument
fallacieux parce que c'est faire des
locataires de bonne foi qui payent
chaque mois et qui bosse chaque mois
pour pouvoir payer donc je trouve que
c'est plutôt insultant vis-à-vis de tous
les catégories qui vous répondent Gilles
Verdez comment vous expliquer monsieur
que toutes les associations qui
s'occupent du logement qui sont
respectables vous les connaissez le
dalle la fondation
contre votre loi je respecte leurs
combats
je respecte leur combat qui a toujours
été celui de lutter contre la précarité
et lutter pour que chacun ait un toit
ils n'ont pas exactement la même vision
de la propriété privée que ce que je
peux avoir ce que vous pouvez avoir ce
que les Français peuvent avoir ils
considèrent que la propriété privée qui
pourtant est consacrée dans la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen
pour eux c'est moins important que le
droit au logement voilà donc c'est une
vision idéologique qui est très
différente donc ils ont un combat
idéologique du droit au logement je le
respecte moi j'ai un combat pour la
propriété privée le respect des petits
propriétaires qui encore une fois une
valeur constitutionnelle donc je
comprends qu'on est du débat c'est
normal qu'on ait du bain d'accord voilà
merci mais ils ont un combat qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas exactement sur la même
longueur non il y a pas que des petits
profils monsieur
député
non mais vas-y mon bébé vas-y merci
beaucoup le le revenu médian des
bailleurs est quand même deux fois plus
élevé que celui des français lambda donc
on parle il y a des exceptions il y a
des petits propriétaires qui en
souffrent bien évidemment mais je suis
assez d'accord avec Gilles sur le fait
que sur le fait que il y a ce qui est
pas normal c'est que des personnes ne
soient pas capable financièrement de
payer des loyers qui sont parfois très
bas donc il y a le cas il y a le cas des
squatteurs violents qui sont là comme ça
et il y a aussi le cas de de personnes
honnêtes qui ne peuvent pas c'est ce
qu'il aillé leur loyer
c'est ce qu'il a dit en préambule et la
loi changera pas grand chose pour eux
d'ailleurs s'ils auront toujours le
temps de régulariser la loi elle va pas
dire du jour au lendemain vous êtes
locataire vous avez perdu votre job non
l'amende dont on parlez elle arrivera au
bout de deux ou trois nouvelles quand le
juge
a dit il faut partir et que la personne
se maintient quand même pardon
excusez-moi
regardez regardez oui à 78%
maintenant
qu'on vous a applaudit tout ça vous
pouvez pas faire quelque chose pour la
retraite à 64 ans
c'est pas la même limonade